enfin quitter sa voiture on ira à lyon
qui viendra vous regardez juste par la
fenêtre découvrir des animaux sauvages
en semi-liberté une première en france
en 1968 paul de la panouse fils du
propriétaire du château de thoiry décide
de créer un parc zoologique unique en
son genre un circuit de 6,5 km parcours
la réserve où différents animaux de la
plaine africaine cohabitent
on dit parfois que les français manquent
d'imagination et notamment dans le
secteur du tourisme mais je pense que
pour une fois j'ai doit pas nous a
montré que nous avons faire aussi bien
que les autres et même mieux puisque
chez de réserve africaine et je crois
unique en europe 50 ans et 22 millions
de visiteurs plus tard le célèbre safari
est toujours là mais le parc s'est
nettement a grandi plus de 750 animaux
sur 150 hectares sont désormais
présentés au public
au départ c'était vraiment la réserve en
voiture aujourd'hui on a énormément
étoffer la partie à pied
on a développé depuis un an ou deux les
activités plein air avec la tyrolienne
avec le safari air park
on a fait un petit renouveau aussi dans
safari avec les camions safari des
activités toujours plus inventifs pour
conserver son côté révolutionnaire le
parc mise sur la modernité
pour fêter son demi siècle il lance la
première édition du happy touahri
festival samedi 2 juin
claudio capéo mais aussi à venir et
arcade yann se produiront dès 19h30
[Musique]
même si le temps
et moi 12
torride
jours